cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com I really want to talk about
the story this is forbes.com Trump
family insists Mar-A-Lago worth over 1
billion dollars after judge calls value
wildly inflated here's what it might
really be worth I'll give you the gist
the judge says it's worth around 18
million dollars that's the amount you
make on Twitter every month that's I I
it's crazy right you know I just as a
humble a humble 18 million
um okay they say anger on the judge the
determination that Trump inflated the
value blah blah is uh based on an
appraisal from Paul Beach County
Assessor which found the market value of
the 17 and a half acre property between
2011 and 2021 to be 18 million and 27.6
million
let me first break down
what is absolutely insane about this
okay anybody who owns property knows the
tax assessed value is not what you list
the property for when you sell it right
so the idea that Trump is being asked
what's it worth he's like well if I was
going to sell it I'd say 400 500 million
the tax assessor saying 30 million
that's the tax assessor that's the
government that's their that's their
business Trump deciding it's worth more
is not him inflating it the government
is in the Arbiter of the value of homes
just the taxation so look at I I got to
tell you man this if this is true this
means every single home buyer has been
defrauded fraud of course so I'm I I'm
you know what this is awesome for me
because what I'm going to do now is I'm
going to take this judge's ruling in New
York I'm gonna go look at some New York
City real estate
two or two to three commercial acres in
Brooklyn with a tax assessed value of
200 000 and I'm gonna go to the person
selling it for 5 million and say if you
don't sell this to me for 200 000 I will
I will have you investigated for fraud
because the value according to this
judge is what the tax assessor says not
you sell it for 200 000 or else and that
strategy is going to work just so long
as the person you say that to is the
leader of the Republican party in an
election year then you're then you're
good exactly exactly but but
not selling you my commercial property
for 20 000. okay then you go and
complain file a suit in this judge's
court go to the teacher James and say
Here's your opportunity to get Trump
prove that you really do think the
property value is what the tax tester
says and sell me this hot five million
dollar property for two hundred thousand
right I mean I mean to be fair I would
be able to sell it after that so I
wouldn't want it right true that would
destroy the property value of New York
the thing about Mar-A-Lago first of all
is it's a super nice club I've only
gotten to go once or twice and I was I
expected it to be kind of cheesy and
gold and trumpy it's it's just a
beautiful extremely well established
Club on beautiful property but even put
that aside for a second
a P.O box in Palm Beach is 18 million
dollars the notion that this very
prominent Club in the prime part of the
Prime Beach is is 18 million it's just
completely absurd yeah well I mean with
inflation in the last three years
inflation if like yeah thirty percent 20
yeah like if something was a dollar it's
a dollar twenty now I mean I don't know
exactly the numbers but like four years
ago our national debt was like 27. I got
billion now it's 34 trillion or
something like that that's I gotta I
gotta build up the value
this is Zillow and this is Mar-A-Lago
Mar-A-Lago goes Beach to beach it's got
water on both sides this is nice this so
so I want you to understand this whole
plot right here and I believe it might
include this plot I'm not sure who owns
this one but this one doesn't have a
listing on it and they said it's Beach
to beach so I would I would imagine it's
probably trumps but I'm not sure okay it
says 24.2 million Zillow in fact a few
years ago it said 400. yeah Zillow
changed it apparently this is my
understanding I read an article that
said that I could be wrong be careful
here but hold on
you see how big it is you see this itty
bitty thing right here 56.8 million wow
something does not make sense why is
Zillow showing Mar-A-Lago 17.5 Acres as
24 million and then up here literally
next to Mar-A-Lago a much much smaller
property and much less valuable because
it's obviously not beach to Beach right
and it's double the price wow so this
property it's off the market let's pull
up the home details it's uh 1.76 Acres
and its estimated value this I want to
make sure this is clear this is a Zillow
estimate not a market appraisal value
Zillow is saying this property is 56
million dollars but Mar-A-Lago is 24.
Mar-A-Lago is
17.51 Acres Beach to Beach and it's a
prop a club that generates 25 million
dollars per year right this little house
right here look at this this little itty
bitty house right here
is worth 2 million more than Mar-A-Lago
in what reality does look at this one
this tiny one right 30 million let me if
you if you pulled up here and said oh
this house is 30 million dollars
and then you look at Mar-A-Lago how come
I can't get the 17 Acres right sell me
that one that's cheaper that's insane
but but of course look there's no logic
to it we we could yell about it until
we're blue in the face they don't care
whatsoever the point of this ruling is
to say hey Trump we took away your
election perhaps and Trump we took away
some of your money and Trump were going
to take away your freedom because we're
going to put you in prison and now we're
going to take away your business just
because just because we want look at
this look at this right here just just
south of Mar-A-Lago on this other side
100 million for for this seven bedroom
100 million yo uh three eight three and
a half acres I'm wondering what the
ramifications of this ruling is going to
be because right now
the people who live in Palm Beach
all of them are angry that a judge just
ruled mar-a-lago's worth 20 million
because now
yeah you're the you invested in property
in West Palm Beach thinking your value
is going to go up someone bought a
property for 20 million now the judge is
saying it's worth less than a million
dollars well forget I mean by The Way
West Palm Beach which is on the mainland
that property is worth a ton of money
we're talking about Palm Beach all right
right we're talking about the real job
West Palm Beach actual Palm Beach like
the number might make some sense in West
Palm Beach but it but it's all just a
forest no one no one takes this
seriously right no one takes the four
indictment seriously no it's it's just
Leticia James who who brought this case
ran for office saying I'm I'm gonna get
Trump this is all going on in New York
why they're talking about Trump's
property in Florida no one even really
knows it's just it's just a joke and the
sad part is
it might work right I mean well it's
going to work if you're in a communist
state where the law doesn't matter yeah
and so in the instant so let me show you
the suite from Kyle Kolinski
Kyle said Mar-A-Lago gets revenue of 25
million a year its value it's valued at
Max 75 million you idiots claimed it's
worth 739 million you did this with
virtually all of your properties to
inflate net worth and get loans from
banks on more favorable terms fraud
Kyle's completely wrong about all of
this yeah and it's shocking because I
like Kyle but this his his past few
tweets on all of this stuff shows that
he didn't actually look in any of it
first of all the Trump family valued the
property between 400 and 600 not 739
second why would the value of a 17 acre
piece of real estate a hard asset only
be valued based on the revenue generated
by the business right if you were to
remove the business outright we're
talking about a piece of property 17
acres in Palm Beach comparables are
would put the comparables of the of the
acreage just the acreage with no
property puts this property at a billion
dollars with no business on it right you
add 25 million a year we're probably
looking at 1.25 to 1.5 billion as a
business property
that's it's just simple the scary thing
about what Kyle is saying is that
his the point he made was that the the
uh Leticia James gave a press conference
that proves it
the judge then issued a summary judgment
with no trial sanctioned Trump's lawyers
banged the gavel and said dissolve the
Trump organizations you committed fraud
no trial no defense no evidence just a a
press conference and the judge says yes
and these people are celebrating it so
you know I was talking to
Andy no and he was asking if it was uh
wrong if I thought it was wrong that
people on the right keep calling the
left Communists because they call people
on the right fascist and I'm like well
the right's not fascist but the left is
communist and I don't mean literally
every single person but there's the
banality of evil and malicious evil
there are people who are working in
service to Communism while not realizing
it and then there are people who are
literally doing it they make the same
argument on the right about fascism the
only problem is Dave Smith who they call
a fascist completely disagrees with
everything Trump does or 99 of it right
so you can't say he's in service
something he does he opposes outright
but this is the narrative they're going
with right now
and now they're actually just I'm I mean
I'm looking at this I tweeted in
response to what Kyle said Carl Benjamin
was just here said you were right they
eventually all just become Communists
they are now basically saying if the
state says so it is so and you know if I
mean one can talk about all the isms all
day long and and uh communism and
socialism are a consequence of
liberalism you know centuries ago but
even just the libs have this problem
which is liberalism boils down to
maximizing individual autonomy and what
that boils down to I mean we see this in
the absurdities of all of the identity
ideologies that have proliferated today
but what that boils down to is a
diminishing of the importance of
objective reality of things like law of
things like I don't know real estate
prices relative to Palm Beach all of
these things that that goes away I mean
if if a man can claim that he is a type
of thing that he is not and be granted
uh you know that that right in society
ID then we're untethered from reality
and so maximum individual expression
makes the law into nothing more than a a
way to wield a cudgel and beat your
enemies and and so we're going to be
debating about the law and the objective
value of this property but they don't
care they're just gonna they're just
gonna smack Trump and I'll just just to
add West Palm Beach point three acre lot
5.5 million dollars point point three
wow so let's do 15 per acre now do 17
acres and uh yeah but you know I mean
think that's West Palm Beach it's kind
of like in a war you know in a war when
the Conqueror conquerors the conquered
he can either say all right give me
tribute payments I own you now you're
conquered give me tribute payments or
they can come up with some silly fakakta
kind of legal document that says well
actually in reparation for the war you
need to pay us x amount but it's it's
just a legal veneer to cover what is
just brutal base sick politics and that
that's what's going on right here so if
if this decision is thrown out which it
certainly should be they'll just do some
other version of it because none of this
has anything to do with the value of
Mar-A-Lago or Trump's businesses or the
bank loans he got or any of it it
obviously only has to do with the 2024
election it has to do with the fact that
they view this man as a danger to their
political project and so if if this
stuff doesn't hold up in court they'll
just kill him at a certain point they're
just gonna kill I mean that is the end
goal of all of this that's what Alex
Jones was saying too not that well that
means it's true I'm just saying he he no
no that is exactly like a plane crash or
something yeah let me let me rephrase it
then you know they will they will kill
him I can't do it yours is better than
mine how are you guys I don't I disagree
I don't think so you don't think I got a
better Alex Jones than Michael you think
mine is I don't think I don't think I
don't think Trump's life is in danger
so uh this this strategy changed a long
time ago a political assassination's
immortalize ideologies you end up with
their faces painted I mean look Kurt
Cobain dies and they paint his face all
over all these buildings in a bunch of
different cities yeah yeah so what they
do now is character assassination which
they do to Trump the problem is it
doesn't work it just doesn't work with
them but this is
I mean this is why I say Civil War
that's why I don't I don't I don't think
that this ends with them being like okay
we have to stop Trump by any means
necessary it starts with them saying the
system has broke there's no there's no
moving forward there's no high conflict
I they definitely don't want to make
them a martyr but that's why they
invented the heart attack gun and stuff
where it doesn't look like an
assassination like he died in his hotel
room
it doesn't matter well I don't want to
talk too much about it John F Kennedy
gets shot and immediately conspiracy
theories the CIA did it and now Ron Paul
comes on Tim Kester Island says it comes
on IRL saying the CIA did it it is now
basically mainstream RFK is saying that
you you can't your heart attack gun it's
not gonna work anything bad happens to
Trump instantly all Trump supporters
believe it was it was malicious
something something bad happened if the
aspartame and Big Macs haven't gotten
them already you know I don't buy a
heart attack okay no they're gonna
they're going for character and they're
destroying his net worth now yeah they
are they are trying to make him a
homeless person that's the only thing
they can do
if anything bad happens to Trump whether
it's an whether it's him being mugged or
is plane crashing or he just has a heart
attack from Big Max and and Diet Coke he
will be immortalized that's it's very
true man so they want to strip them of
their wealth you want them to Fade Into
Obscurity and be forgotten about you
want their children to have no no errors
no titles you don't want any of that
because that's just a headache in the
future so they're trying to take it all
away from him and his family exactly
especially digital banishment so what do
they do so one you've got the
prosecutions put them in prison
immobilize him basically strip him of
his resources strain him so he can't run
and can't be as influential they are
basically just attaching as many weights
as possible to drop so so they make him
ineffective
the next thing we just saw them do a
judge summarily ruled that means there's
no trial a judge just banged a gavel the
Trump organization is to be dissolved in
10 days yeah so what's that some random
judge just said yeah now do they be like
okay nah we're gonna do some real laws
yeah uh well they're filing an appeal
but what will happen because we are in
we are in civil Strife territory Civil
War territory this judge says it you
know for a fact New York Democrat
government is going to be like oh well
right canceled Trump organization
dissolved there's there's not going to
be some principled person in the
Democrat Trifecta New York State going
well I mean this is a little crazy for
the judge to rule this I don't think no
they're going to be like okay hopefully
there's wealthy businessmen in the
Democratic party that are going to be
like this could happen to me if they can
just go bang bang and dissolve people's
never a selfless thought like that no
there are a few you guys like do we want
to live in a world where Trump has
nothing left to lose isn't that a little
bit scary get on baby let's go then what
he has now and also since he's been you
know digitally banished like you said
Ian why is he still waiting to come back
to Twitter
platform he has left I mean he's not
really using it right but he did post
the mug shot that's why that's it though
but he's he's not saying enough he's
it's because whatever he posts on truth
is instantly reposted already yeah but
when he does post on X it's major
breaking news huge so he's he's using
that like like bike shot I do wonder if
if this goes through if this ridiculous
judge in Leticia James get their way uh
does it really matter I mean one will it
dissolve the Trump organization but two
it's not like Donald Trump makes
automobiles you know it's not like
Donald Trump makes widgets the company
is him it's just him it's his name it's
his face it's his lifestyle it's his
impromature on various other products so
can't he just start it again they can't
just be Trump organization too Electric
Boogaloo and you know this one's going
to be registered in Tennessee instead of
New York but I mean I think they're
seizing the properties I mean how is
this going to operate some of the pro
some of the companies that are being
dissolved are just holding companies
right so uh what so for people aren't
familiar when you're buying a property
you form an LLC which owns the company
but they're gonna they're gonna take his
actual properties but who if they're
dissolving the company then who retains
ownership of the property they've
dissolved The Entity that owns it yeah
fires I don't know can we start bidding
on it they're calling it the corporate
death penalty if the company owns the
property and the company gets dissolved
who owns the property
so that it goes to auction at that point
and that's crazy if if you as a human
being Ian Crossland own property and
then you're 80 years old and you pass on
and you have no next of kin or whatever
who gets the property well the state
will probably just take it I think
that's what happens if you die and
there's no one else or it goes here next
of kin or whatever a corporation doesn't
have any of that the corporation is gone
where does the property go I imagine it
would be the same as if somebody died I
just don't know I mean that's just so
that is like Fidel Castro level stuff
and I don't I I don't doubt that they
want to do it I just can't imagine the
American people put up with that I
assume there have got to be some
reasonable Democrats I know that's a bad
assumption but people who don't want the
entire system of business law to be
totally upended in the United States
just because they hate the mean orange
man but maybe not maybe they're
irrational enough to do something like
that I I think you're right you know
it's just a matter of people being aware
of what the hell is happening a lot of
times too I just love this is also
another species of one of the dumb
anti-trump attacks which is you know
he's not really that rich I always loved
that in 2016. some guy who doesn't have
two pennies to rub together you know
Trump's actually if he's broke like well
he flies around in a 747 for his entire
adult life so I if he's broke he's doing
a good job fooling all of us he's living
off my head he knows how to work the
system
and not pay it back if you know if
you're a good business it's not that he
doesn't he does pay it back you pay back
as little as possible just to keep the
banks happy and then you use it all that
loan that investment money to reinvest
to make more than the the interest that
you owe you have you have a billion
dollars cash in a a 999 million cash out
and then a million in your pocket every
month or something like that so it's a
massive rotation but I loved when they
were saying Donald Trump's a failed
businessman he's had five bankruptcies
or whatever
success in business if you can pull off
a successful bankruptcy yeah but it's
not that it's that bankruptcy doesn't
mean you've lost it's bankruptcy
protection to preserve the business
secondly Trump had over 500 businesses
and only a small handful uh that's
bankruptcy then they said whatever
happened to Trump Stakes or Trump
magazine or Trump water see where are
those things and I was like all of those
things are at Trump's Golf Resorts
go to Trump Doral and you will get a
bottle of trump water you will see a
trump mag you will be delivered a trump
stake to your room what they don't
understand is these companies Trump
started are just Trump supplying his own
product to cut costs for his Golf
Resorts vertical integration yeah right
McDonald's makes their own mayonnaise
yes exactly but also McDonald's brand
managed it's not in stores they failed I
mean he tried you know he tried the
Airlines and now he's just got his plane
but right but and they say see he failed
at that Airline I I've noticed that
every single successful person on planet
Earth has failed a lot of times that is
that is one of the markers of success
and most of them have failed more than
anyone has even tried to succeed at
anything else so I just don't see how
that even that's enough well of the 5
000 things the man's ever done one of
them flops like okay that's pretty good
yeah not bad I have a university like
his biggest flop Trump University was
probably the silliest flight yeah But I
don't it was it wasn't the biggest
property he had though and also I have a
PhD from there I heard it was a scandal
is it real what was the Scandal about
Trump well it's not like you know it's
it's not a school like um you know
Stanford or Harvard or something meaning
if you send your kid to Trump University
the kid won't end up trans you know or
hate you when they graduate
it's it's it's the whole accreditation
system in my opinion is meaningless it's
not accredited well I don't know if it
was I don't believe it was I think it
was just like a kind of scammy sounding
company but who you know there's like a
million of these things I think it was
more so that it just didn't get going
yeah Trump try to start a thing gotta
people and went nowhere and then it fell
apart and they were like yo what the you
know yeah but I mean does anyone really
think Trump University is more of a scam
than like half of the actually
accredited universities in America today
it's less of a scam you're right thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time